This is Queen’s Freddie Mercury,
on September 19, 1980.
And next to him is lead guitarist, Brian May,
who in July 2021 returned to find his
Kensington, London home flooded.
He blamed “the basement building that has
been plaguing this area for the past 10 years.”
From 2008 to 2019, 7,328 basements
were added to homes in London.
Basements not just for the rich.
But the superrich.
All of these dots represent private,
underground swimming pools...
and cinemas...
and wine cellars.
Click to London’s top luxury realtors,
sort by price,
and you’ll find underwater playgrounds,
and theatres.
Homes like this 25 million pound one with
two basement levels,
including a bar...
and spa.
London's elite are building underground lairs.
So it's an interesting kind of conflict
between these different
very, very wealthy people.
Or as we said, I think in one paper, we say
it's a conflict between the haves
and the have yachts.
I'm professor Roger Burrows and
I'm professor of cities
in the School of Architecture, Planning, and Landscape
at Newcastle University.
But I'm not an architect, nor am I a planner.
I'm essentially a sociologist and a statistician.
Do you remember how y'all got the idea though?
Was it literally just, you're
walking down the street,
you see a ton of construction trucks
all the time,
and you wonder "Why is there always
construction on this street?"
And then you say,
"Oh, I bet they're making a basement."
Exactly.
We were doing a case study of four or five
different neighborhoods in London
and we were interviewing residents about
what was happening in the neighborhood.
We would notice as we were doing this,
the streets with five or six of these
excavations going on at the same time
with lorries moving up and down.
And indeed the people that we're interviewing
really just wanted to talk about it
because they felt that their neighborhood
was being ruined.
Each borough in London has a planning commission
where people have to submit renovation plans.
Burrows and his coauthors searched every application
and found all the basements.
And then mapped them.
Mostly it's concentrated around the great
parks around Hyde Park, Kensington, Chelsea
and Hammersmith and Fulham.
Brian May’s house, in Kensington, had an
original half-underground floor.
Suddenly, his neighbors were all building
basements of an entirely different scale.
A well-off neighborhood became extremely well-off.
Transnational elites were literally burying
millions and millions of dollars in the ground.
So, this isn't as much of a thing in America.
Do you have a sense why that is?
Is it the historic codes in London?
You can't really change the outside appearance
of a property.
You can't build a loft and you can't
extend at the back.
But because of the freehold laws,
you own all of the land under the property,
so you can burrow down.
A lot of it is also geological.
New York is another kind of world city where
you might expect these things to be occurring.
That happened a little bit in Brooklyn,
but you're literally trying to mine a rock.
The great thing about London is,
of course, it's clay.
So it's very easy to dig down
and generate these spaces.
Burrows and his coauthors mapped standard,
large,
and mega-basements.
What we call mega basements
are three stories or more.
Or, two stories, but which extend
beyond the envelope.
We find 118 of those and they're on
a ginormous scale.
This map shows their concentration
in wealthy neighborhoods.
The combination of incredible wealth
and inflexible exteriors
led to massive basement builds.
Wine cellars, gyms, art galleries,
ballrooms, panic rooms, gun stores.
In the late 1800s, a ship owner named Charles Booth
started tracking inequality in London,
a gradient that he mapped,
from wealth to poverty,
compiled through extensive surveys.
There is now a clear, what we call,
basement belt in London
concentrated within particular neighborhoods
in particular streets.
So I think it is a physical manifestation
of gross wealth inequality.
In the mid 2010s, London boroughs began to
curb permits for multilevel basements
because of resident concerns, like those of
Queen's Brian May’s.
The consequences are more than just flooding.
Deep digging can cause structural collapses.
But basement construction hasn't stopped completely.
Gianluca Vialli was one of the best
Italian strikers in the 1980s and 90s.
When he moved to London in 1996, his legend
only grew as he moved into management.
He helped lead Italy to win
the Euro 2020 final.
In 2020, he appeared in the lower right corner
of a video conference stream
begging the Kensington and Chelsea
Applications committee
not to let his neighbors expand their basements,
after he’d lived through earlier construction.
Today, his neighbor's house is for sale.
It's lavish. There's also
one major selling point:
the planning board has granted permission
for a basement excavation.